there's an even there's an even bigger
holiday toy said the the world's first
lovable robot dog sounds intriguing
let's listen to the commercial can't
hear it
meet Chet walk yeah keep an eye on much
more than just a gadget pause there
first
yeah why are you meowing youma it's not
funny
go ahead
perhaps it's there to greet you at the
door
what stops Marvin chip recognizes who
his owner is
oh yeah I know yo that's my food [ __ ]
have you seen my other slipper yeah did
your wife scooter one year
look I'm gonna tinkle all over your
[ __ ] feet man I don't think that the
robot dog is hazel there's new things so
you can teach him tricks
I know trick smarter ship becomes I'm
[ __ ] smart i watch this trick i'll
suck my own Becca just press the like
button on the van
you got a pause when Jim's talking
because otherwise the punch lines are
going over the setups for the next you
know that's just it's okay now yeah you
try an alright let's how many badges do
you think you learn you know as I don't
know what the badges are because I was
ever play I couldn't fit in there as
chip gets smarter he earns more badges
that's I got like 300 300 bad girls Wow
what are they for everything like one
just being smart yeah it's not a badge
man she moved it back a little bit I so
badly once I want to take this
commercial and take Jim's audio I think
my favorite Robin my nose where your
nose when we asked him also some
whatever part so far has been the dog
greeted the dog will greet you at the
door stop stupid
all right let's I want to get to know
chip a little more I want to find out if
this is something because I mean
you know I want to find out if I should
get it for her for Christmas but he also
learns new things so you can teach him
tricks and the smarter ship becomes not
the more badges here give me a badge
with my badge [ __ ] give you a [ __ ]
badge you been [ __ ] cursing your owner
she's hogging all the badges she hides
them in a CUDA no I thought that's where
the slipper would welcome bad he said
the slipper was in the cooler now
somebody else is coated with a [ __ ]
badge [ __ ] bad you have to earn them
by being a sinner I earned that you have
to do tricks to get badges yeah I do
tricks what kind of tricks [ __ ] tell
jokes make people laugh now the one like
what you see just press the like button
on the van
yep get a badge it hurts him to behave
or be a little mischievous okay I'm not
gonna block Soho [ __ ] [ __ ] I knocked
a [ __ ] block Silva your choice has
changed she go back I want to see that
again
I'm misty vyas that's Judith watch this
jump the ramp here you go
[ __ ] [ __ ] dr. block Silva wait
cursing at the little girl who's playing
with blocks Noctem blocks Alva
she's just hitting 911 those blocks why
would she say that she's a little girl
stop funny to make 911 references
[ __ ] knock them block Silva that's a
charming yeah it is Oh
people laughing your choices change
ships behavior yes Jesus personality I
can be onerous I can be sexy I can be
handsome sexy yep I can be humorous oh
no two chips are ever alike that's right
we're all different like a bunch of
snowflakes but what yo ma chip is
did experience no he has a translator
now now it's a chip so you can
understand his thoughts I want to look
Laird out touch my pecker your robot dog
you don't even have a pecker I do Earl
shoot side of the sound girl smartphone
smartphone my fetch yep give me I'll get
the ball is the answer together hit the
ball that I'll hide it now you go
[ __ ] look for I'm busy doing what
[ __ ] chillin really think you're a
cute dog don't you on my wheels and [ __ ]
I'll run your [ __ ] feet over
oops-a-daisy why would you do I would
like my badge
welcome [ __ ] not getting a badge for
cursing my badge you're not gonna get a
badge for cursing and running people
over yeah you're not yeah I'm not a
robot dog Oh sensors so you can maneuver
around obstacles with ease
yep what the mobile lab you can seach it
I'm hungry
it's my [ __ ] dinner she's feeding it
a mobile app some cake for the chipper
yeah how about a little cake for the
chipper how about a little cake for the
chip [ __ ] I don't know if the app can
handle that stop drooling
don't you care and that's important
because when you're unneeded no matter
it bigger small he's there for you I'm
always there Tweety just chased everyone
around the house laughing who's laughing
me the whole place why if I grew up
everybody
yeah you're a dog why would you laugh
it's cute
this is beacon sense technology chip is
fully aware of his surroundings always I
always know what's going on right now it
is Sam this Travis does Derek there's a
chair that's actually really good you I
know all my surroundings where's Mike or
whatever it is maybe you should get a
badge for that I should get a badge
about a little bad for the chip huh
spitting seriously
no one's seen it
this is like the fifth time a lot of
flippers gone I'll get it for you
hold on a second where's the slipper I
gotta pull it out of the CUDA first how
to return to his bed when it's time for
a charge yeah get a charge without my
pot goes right in my butthole I sit on
the charger thing goes right my butthole
you're getting it charged yeah put that
little charged thing right my butthole
charge up the tip of a laughter Joey
spent a lot of time as a young boy
getting charged no I didn't I bet you
did a garbage I betcha textual innuendo
yo I slip up I'll get your slipper where
to that lady's Kota I'm going to run
fish it out with my dog nails Oh chip is
a smart device yeah you dance sketchy
there's a robot chip is a dog yep chip
as a humourist chip as a lover are you
Maurice yeah jeez hilarious right y'all
have friend me and Sammi are friends
you notice that I found that slipper
where was it that lady's cooly keep
saying that you notice they didn't
mention that you were hilarious even
once yeah they did
no they did in the beginning of a
commercial but stupid ran over it you
really let that play while you were
talking about a lot for quite a while
huh double it up on the chip huh huh yep
I see best time chief I brought the
slipper the girls happy baby slipper in
the slipper kind of a mess give it to
your father to kind of gross to the
touch
blue eyes and [ __ ] you have blue eyes
I'll bow why is that I'm a robot what
kind of a robot [ __ ] adorable
I see dog yeah look my PEC up the heat
what I'll help you like I couldn't do it
send the sound of your robot dog Packer
becoming a wreck yep that's my Pekka
hitting her Woody Woodpecker ankles do
you realize you said pecker twice in
that sentence if they did halfway
through yeah that's I thought good
you said woody would and then realized
you had to say pecker again yep yep
oh it's made by wowie wowie I don't know
there's Gary oh this could be a great
Christmas toy Bob Kelly she's his kid
wanted he wouldn't get it for you
wouldn't right now
you can't chip the dog off